the Bucks has been staggering and
Miami's offense has been on fire and
Butler has it right here with a
15-footer over holiday we'll talk about
on fire right how good has Jimmy Butler
been in this series Butler and to 17 in
the first quarter in game three and it
was huge a screen by love and Drive by
Jimmy Butler
performance already with 11. Giannis
who's got seven and just like that the
heat down by 12 now Trail by 20. 50
three-point shooting against Miami
here's a long shot
he didn't win I spent on the perimeter
of love
[Music]
the curl around and put it in love with
the rebound the outlet goes to gate
Vincent in stride is Cutler puts on the
breaks in a 14 footer Jimmy Butler is
all the manic 11 points he's hit four
consecutive shots boy his first quarters
have been Dynamic that's the line he
cannot miss
some shits shooting the basketball from
Deep
15 points last game after a combined
seven in the first two a second block
right there for Lopez
Jimmy Butler's a machine
ends off to Robinson who's the number
one three-point shooter so far in these
playoffs
up and down up and down
how did he pull that out of his pack of
tricks and a little team Joe Ingles just
a little bit slight bump right there and
Butler just wanted to get it up on the
backboard little did he know
sometimes prayers are answered
this is unbelievable Butler will
maneuver that by out of the bones
defense shot clock at nine
Butler
he is having a first quarter for the
ages Butler goes up against Allen
butler two in the second 22 in the first
and places run through right there
at holiday is right there good Defender
is holiday thinking gets it up and in as
he was thrashing away with the defensive
minded holiday
[Music]
and lost the ball on a turnover for the
ball well a holiday is a great defender
seven to play in the third across the
lane it's Butler and Lopez right on with
the whistle counted foul
is the biggest tonight for the bucks who
have never trailed
37.
[Music]
Middleton
rebound chased and saved by Lopez and
intercepted by Robinson while we
Defenders and Butler pulls up over the
holidays shot clock at nine Middleton
with Butler driving right into it count
it fouls
especially against Chris Middleton
there's the contact the concentration
41.
[Applause]
and Giannis was trying to call time out
gets the ball to Jimmy Butler 44 big one
46 points for Jimmy Butler
what's up
[Applause]
why not Jimmy Butler
has done it again
[Applause]
or he's going to get an easy lay-in
is the one they called a long two for
Butler
so that's why you attack early here